si no così è oggi nuova challenge estivi
contro alex lavorando alle viste i box
abbiamo appunto varie mistery box e ogni
turno sceglieranno la uno la 23 a 463
farà il mistery box ci può essere un
live schifoso oppure uno slide super
strong che sono i nuovi live della
skifidol anzi cinque no 2 in ogni scatto
loro indiscrezioni fortunati prendiamo
la scatola visto il box con lo slime
strong della skifidol altrimenti avremo
lo slam schifo che riposo chi prende più
slime skifidol vincerà come lo sai che
cosa facciamo la no la james per
stronghold dorato e bellissimo lecce non
ci prendi il secondo posto il suo lello
slice furto ma che argentato quindi
vediamo chi riuscirà a vincere 1 0
sequestrandone oppure lo sly un super
strong argentato che invece a
collezionare più slam straw 63 kg
mostrando sarà un punto prontissimo su
persone si sono doris colori diversi
sono anche profumatissime potete
trovarlo in edicola in allegato alla
rivista a tre over 50 siamo pronti
allora vediamo chi inizia carta far
risultato
cominciamo allora puoi chiedere da letto
di sceglierla mettere box alexa segno un
numero tra 1 e 2 22 anni con tassi e
quindi avrebbe fretta siamo pronti alla
norma il 3 2
la marrone vita e tu invece questo fu
ruota il rossoblù ora io ho questo qui
fluo
noi abbiamo rivediamo come l'abbiamo
ufficio dorato andiamo a vedere come
sono
allora vediamo un po quindi questo è
glitter un po argentato e questo fu rosa
dai nostri li voglio dirlo questa
lettera
sentiamola bene mutu che buona tipo
vaniglia
che bello rochy in pratica si è scritto
che sono sopra lunga bili distruttibili
abbiamo visto anche dal video dei me
contro te che provano a tirarlo
tantissimo ma sono indistruttibili
quindi possiamo tirar lo potete vedere
un morbidissimo è una sorta di squizzi
antistress cammello glitter dentro
questa volta si allunga e provare ancora
tutto tutto dotta dottori tevere
scampati fragola è fortissimo non voglio
io ha negato al glee per dio
sì c'è qualche tutte le palline e rosa
però che profumo fa proprio un area tira
vento e mi guarda che mondadori che ha
dobbiamo provare a rintracciarli tipo
iii c
scampato il mesi sono stata spiegata al
28 2008
non so neanche quando abbiamo fatto
questo slam in quale si allena mazzarri
bile chimici occupato un ufficio cos'è
anche l'autore non è molto buona
però a giudicare dal colore direi che
questo potrebbe essere uno slide fatto
domanda allora è vero non c'entrano
niente
sicuramente questo l'ho fatto io guardo
che bruciano i glitter li orrendi ovvio
tempo visto almeno non è appiccicoso
però due punti quindi vediamo adesso che
visto il boss di carta con allora che
non vi sono 34
alex ha scelto un numero tra 3 e 4 3
quindi questo ok vediamo dirigente
[Musica]
perfetta insomma troppo fortunato da
zero
e invece io no che cos'è quella cosa con
la pallina che bello ha fatto è carino
ha comunque un colore un po motore un po
meno
capita allora verde fluo
poi abbiamo il vicino e poi abbiamo il
ce ne sono ma non vederli allora vediamo
un po spenti ha sciolto strano questo di
live non sempre dalle inchieste
singolare sembra coca cola scrutati sì
un po il diritto non so in quale sales
lo abbiamo fatto
poi c'e latinos e non ha proprio un buon
odore
quindi queste il news live sfigato ma
meglio peccato che si intuisce che a
questo colore antica ritter però io
almeno quello allora cominciamo prima
non questo celeste sentire l'odore buono
sa di mare vedere e poi a celestino a
non creare 0
vediamo quella merda ebook super verde è
presto per dire ma ci mostra una
caramella gommosa una caramella gommosa
limone quello verde con la saletta 26
mila euro
il verde perché fluo a me piace questa
scadenza perché in teoria tanto lontano
dall è vero dunque rubrica societari
minato la serenità di scegliere se io
numero a caso tra 5 e 6 auto ora siamo
stati mettono a parlare consigli perché
non gli piace il numero 6 perché pensa
che io quando di costei voglia dire tu
sei le mose scegliere un muro 357 scegli
un numero tra 5 e 7 allora niente siri
oggi è arrabbiatissimo e non si vola
rispondere assurdo quindi li chiederò di
tirare il vado invece di scegliere il
numero vediamo se capita 15 16 tina il
dato finalmente maledetta crisi assetto
la scatola numero 6 non eliminiamo le
basiliche poi dopo si arrabbia ancora
nati
e non voglia di giocare col mondo
facciamo perché non pochino aperta fino
alle elezioni misti per questo l'ho
fatto io
forti venti però questo è carino perché
esso perché piano piano zeppo di cose
dentro però è attivato troppo
vogliamo giochi cimberio all on line
strong blu o arancione che superfluo tra
l'altro e poi o lo slime rav un razzo
glitter bello anche bercy colori assieme
quindi non aprirli vediamo allora
vediamo un po come questo rosso v.all
glitter e rossi dentro che velico razza
sono un po oscuri così si vedono come t
a me sembrano delle caramelle gommose
super striscioni tra l'altro a queste
sono molto anti stress
amatissimo tra tutti belle queste
professioni perché si possono conservare
il bene chiudo poi arancione con dentro
i glitter arancioni insomma che sono
arancioni clip
questo è un po più killer infatti si
vede solo governo lo vedete sfilarlo ti
fai ha detto lo stesso qualcosa che
questo ma vediamo ora vitale cosa gli è
capitato che avevamo utilizzato la colla
chiara trasparente e poi lo volevamo
lasciare per farlo diventare cli ari
fate
basta adesso vediamo un po e un po dura
action
oddio non non si stacca ma non si sa
tirò appetito diciamo che è veramente
veramente molto attivato e tutto
brillante chiesa allora che in effetti
che è un reader
l'ho fatto io percorribile ma nei miei
mare dai carina ok siamo al penultimo
turno che va da far risultato
noi vediamo se series comporta bene
proponiamo perché nel dato non c'è il 7
el 8 quindi doverle il numero sceglie il
numero a caso tra uno e otto finalmente
allora abbiamo dovuto dire tra uno e
otto e non tra sette otto perché
altrimenti il tiri non capisce e non
vuole essere un po tonto oggi si è
svegliata male si è arrabbiata comunque
assente il numero 7 e quindi questo nome
vediamo franti 32
è viva
slide to be strong o quella giallo e poi
quello celeste lui io beccato con l'agi
lo slide show man tobey non vedo la tv
[Musica]
ora c'è questo celeste fluo buschi
vediamo il profumo di mare di spiaggia
di vacanze al mare e su questo superando
un grado in area fighetto capitale dopo
comunque questo flussi listino
bellissimo e poi amo il giallo anche
questo è un uomo mite giallissimo non
moricola vagone di limonata fresca
allora vediamola slam schifo grigio
evento non ho parole dai aprile
è cresciuto un po ha un buon profumo di
schiuma da barba come adesso è grigio è
che tu sia fatto di fortunati lamentose
21 sì sotto sotto però non è purtroppo
glossy tutti almeno anche non mi piace
glossy farà anche di internet è infatti
certo che l'avevo fatto tardi e che
tutti i grigi lo guarda
sono contentissimo che si è sciolto
tutto rischiarlo un po da almeno da
questa parte che non è sciolto ok quale
si è sciolto ma non troppo e molto male
è brutto
siamo in parità 4 a testa
quando io quadrati di pareti questo è
l'ultimo round infatti dobbiamo stare
superattenti speriamo che all ex siri
sceglieranno bene neanche sentir ce l'ha
con me mozzini oggi la bravissima come
sempre brava l'ex alexa sei bravissima
grizi supercar in alexa brava gru che
questo il turno decisivo chi prende gli
slime super strong a questo turno avrà
vinto e si aggiudicherà lo slam i super
strong l'odorato quindi pratica è stata
visitata
a loro volta dai questi sono i numeri 9
10 di questo gigante alexa sceglie un
numero tra 9 e 10 nome la squadra di
harry potter franti sono moltissimo 321
[Risate]
viola verde a questi floyd la narrativa
che puzza anche questo l'ho fatto io ma
questo era sotto 2000 perché quando io
non ero così brutto allora io ho il
viola glitter mi fa bimbi preferito
questo perché a tanti scambio oltre a
essere viola lilla ha tantissimi glitter
dentro e sono celesti e rosa bellissimo
questo mio preferito vediamo che profuma
di libertà caramella caramella la
fragola tipo sono anche a poter così noi
abbiamo un bluff quindi vuol dire che
s'illumina
lui o questo verde che morello
non è quello il limone verde lime
vediamo l'attività le tante
alex ha scelto male questa volta almeno
non è liquidato che non ti muovere
artiste indurita un po ci sono i glitter
ci sono le fishbowl no dai non è male eh
sì ma solo l'odore un po strano e anche
l'aspetto sopra un pochettino grumo
casarini sotto il po più grosse po
strano questo slime agazzi è stranissimo
il colore non capisco che colora e si sa
è un colore maschera di halloween
voi vi ricordate in palazzine già
abbiamo fatto per questo nel botto
tubero non l'ho fatto io forse l'ho
fatto io perché ci sono fondi ci sono
poche fishbowl mi dicono ah no che
copriamo tutto questo devo giocare con
gli slide super strong che ci attendiamo
i premi io 1 2 3 4 5 e 6 slime super
strong tu invece hai 1 2 3 e 4 4 quindi
quello dorato il primo posto va a me
è invece tu avrai quello che vediamo un
po come è proprio questo è il argentato
questo abbia presentato stati vani
lingua è scappato un buon odore della
sorpresa vaniglia e questo dorato invece
vediamo un po come comune proprio gol
maturato il cloud drive la stessa di
vaniglia possano sostituì di famiglia al
ahmar ha chiuso il premio fu anche un
ottimo per fare esercizio in effetti
ticolo problema attrezzata dovrebbe alla
treccia ho paura che mi ha inviato gio
rappresentato è fichissimo e adesso con
te una preparazione che bello
intrecciato è fighissimo è ancora più
strong
sono super fortissimo che bello
quindi sono decisamente molto spesso si
è molto antistress magari mentre
studiate se siete nervosi
prendetelo di questi effetti la fuga i
tre giovani abbiamo intrecciato due
problemi a rompere mantenere corso lato
e toni tenere questo però prima 1 solo
professore tutto il mondo che ne abbiamo
intrecciati 4 non so se ti vede ma sono
giganti che bello in tv abbiamo deciso
per descrivere con i commenti qual è il
vostro colore preferito
per me il mio preferito è bello e fatto
viola con i glitter e oggi per colorado
super acceso la fibra che quel giorno
fece tanto il colore che vedeva i
commenti qual è il vostro colore
preferito di questi slime lasciate un
bel live se vuole prendere altre
challenge tiri contro alexa e ora vi
lasciamo a quattro cartellini e si può
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite la
buona visione